joining us now Texas Senator Ted Cruz is
with us
[Applause]
said the Democrats you're up for
re-election in the cycle and they have
targeted you as one of their the top
Republicans that they want to go after
uh emerging everybody to support your
campaign I'm certainly supporting it um
well glad you're back
um you said every city in this country
now is a border City Joe Biden said
yesterday he expects chaos because of
his own policies how is that possible
uh look we have a president who's AWOL
who's not doing his job and we have a
national security crisis unfolding on
our Southern border on Monday the border
patrol apprehended over 10 000 illegal
immigrants yesterday the border patrol
apprehended over ten thousand illegal
immigrants those are both records
we're seeing now title 42 expired there
are over 170 000 illegal immigrants
right on the other side of the Border
preparing to cross I'm going to be down
on the southern Border tomorrow and and
this is a full-on Invasion it is a
crisis and the Biden Administration is
cheering it on they are admit they want
this to happen they want more people to
come in and they don't care about the
body bags that are piling up they don't
care about the women being sexually
assaulted they don't care about the
children being brutalized they don't
care about the over 100
000 drug overdoses that we had last year
two-thirds of which was from Chinese
fentanyl coming across the southern
border and I got to tell you my home
state of Texas is paying the price and
in Texas we are Furious about it we're
frustrated you know Sean you mentioned
my re-elect campaign that I'm running
right now Democrats nationally Chuck
Schumer has made me the Democrats number
one Target in the country my last elect
was the most expensive Senate race in
U.S history they outspent us three to
one and and so I want to urge your
viewers go to tedcruz.org Ted Cruz dot
org Ted Cruz dot org because my radical
left-wing Democrat opponent in the first
36 hours of his campaign raised over two
million dollars they are flooding cash
into this race and so please come to Ted
Cruz dot org because we are going to
defend Texas and we are going to fight
to stop this lawlessness in our Southern
border you know
see
I support your candidacy you know it's
amazing you have these uh Sanctuary
cities and states but then when Governor
Abbott sends illegal immigrants to New
York City or they end up in beautiful
Martha's Vineyard
um or Chicago Lori lightweight was
sending any illegal immigrants you know
to the suburbs they don't want them they
want them in principle they want open
borders but just not our city so they
want Texas to be overwhelmed uh I praise
Governor Abbott he's doing everything in
his power but it's impossible for any
one state to handle this
yeah look the the volume is is so
massive that it defies words and you're
right Democrat Mayors are are freaking
out and declaring a crisis the Democrat
mayor of Chicago the Democrat mayor of
Washington D.C the Democrat mayor where
you are in New York City declares it a
crisis when he gets even a few illegal
immigrants we've had over six and a half
million cross under Joe Biden and 50
show up at Martha's Vineyard and the
woke lefties there declared it a full-on
humanitarian crisis as you know I filed
legislation for the federal government
to send illegal immigrants to Martha's
Vineyard to Nantucket to Rehoboth Beach
to Napa Valley to every place Rich
liberals sip wine wine and eat cheese
and and say well it's not our problem
because they're terrified when it
actually becomes their problem they just
want to inflict it on the rest of
America all right Senator Ted Cruz thank
you as always hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else